[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: --developer
community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
ERIC GILMORE: Hello, I'm Eric
Gilmore, technical writer for
the Google Drive SDK.
And I'm here today
with Ali Afshar,
engineer for Google Drive.
We're going to talk
a little bit about
downloads in Google Drive.
Aren't we, Ali?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah,
that's right.
So in my mind, downloads is one
of the two major use cases
of the Google Drive SDK.
Google Drive SDK allows
you to manage your
files in Google Drive.
It manages user files.
Now, you can get them in.
Downloading allows you
to get them out.
And we have three different
ways of downloading files.
And today, we're going to go
through, in a bit of an
interactive way, using a Python
shell to make some of
these requests, and have a look
at some of the responses,
and see how to download files.
ERIC GILMORE: Viewers, you
are in for a treat.
Ali is going to weave some
Python spells for us.
ALI AFSHAR: Yes.
Something like that.
So should we get started
straight away?
ERIC GILMORE: Why not?
ALI AFSHAR: OK, cool.
So the first thing we're
going to do is the most
standard use case.
A file is in Google Drive.
And we'd like to download
it with the API.
So this is without any
user interaction.
Now, I've got a Python
shell open here.
I'm not sure you can see it.
It uses bpython, which is
a bit nicer than Python.
It gives you co-completion and
other things like that.
I recommend you try it.
It has a good history and
that kind of thing.
So one thing you haven't
seen me do is I've
created an auth molecule.
And inside my auth molecule, I
perform all the authorization
that's required for this.
So I've done that in
the background.
We're not going to deal
with any auth today.
So I just import that, and that
HTTP is an instance which
is already authorized.
It's already got the correct
credentials.
And I'm going to create a
drive service from this.
So from API client, discovery
import build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC GILMORE: Does Drive
service operate as one?
ALI AFSHAR: That's exactly
what it is.
ERIC GILMORE: OK.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Because we've passed in the
authorized HTTP instance and
that's made it authorized.
So all the future calls will
have the correct token
associated there.
Right, so should we make
a call to the API?
ERIC GILMORE: Let's do.
ALI AFSHAR: So Drive--
ERIC GILMORE: But we're not
going to make one call,
though, are we?
ALI AFSHAR: Well, we'll
make a few.
We'll make a few.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALI AFSHAR: So that's
my document.
That's a good one for
me to download
for our second example.
And let's look at
the second file.
And that's an image, so
another good one.
We're going to use that
for our first example.
ERIC GILMORE: So for the first
example, we're going to
retrieve the download URL and
perform a simple download.
Is that right, Ali?
ALI AFSHAR: That's right.
That's exactly right.
So once we've got this thing,
we need to look at the
download URL inside our file.
And you can see there, that's
a reasonably long URL.
It's important to know this
is not a permanent URL.
This will not last forever.
So each time you want to use it,
you should really get the
metadata, find the download
URL from the metadata, and
then use it from there.
How long does it last?
I'd say a few hours.
But to be safe, I would make the
request, get the download
URL, and then use it.
So url=f2 downloadUrl.
OK, and we've got
this URL here.
Now how do we get it?
We have to make an authorized
get request.
So as I've told you, the HTTP
instance is already
authorized.
So I just need to pass
that to HTTP request.
And that returns a two
pull of the response
headers and the content.
So we'll do that request.
It's going away.
It's downloaded.
We can look at the
headers here.
OK, it doesn't really
tell you much.
The status header is
injected for you.
So you see we've got a 200.
You should have a file
name in there.
So r content disposition
is there.
So that tells you what the file
name should be and what
the various content types are.
Well, we can't actually
look at the
binary data of the file.
Why?
Because that would mess
up this terminal.
So let's look and see
how long it is.
ERIC GILMORE: We have ways
of viewing it there.
ALI AFSHAR: We have ways
of viewing it.
So it's 316K, 317K big.
So we're not going to pipe
that to a terminal.
What we will do is
open a file.
Let's open it in binary
right format,
f.write(c) and f.close.
Now, in the terminal, we
have limited options.
So we'll just jump out of
that shell and have
a look at the file.
What do you think, Eric?
Do you think that's
going to work?
ERIC GILMORE: I would love
to look at the file.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, image
to text, maybe?
Img2txt.
That's right, im2txt,
with no zero.
So we look at that, and
there's the file.
What does that look
like to you, Eric?
ERIC GILMORE: That looks like
what I see after drinking a
bottle of wine.
ALI AFSHAR: [LAUGHS]
OK, well.
Let's go to Google Drive.
And let's have a look at what
that file actually is.
There you go, it's my neighbor's
dog, who's making a
few appearances in
these Hangouts.
But there you go.
So that's the image.
I've showed you how to download
it using the download
URL, and then how to save it
just by opening a file in
binary format, writing
that file, and then
you can look at it.
It's on your local system.
OK, back to the shell.
ERIC GILMORE: Can I say, just in
simplest terms, you've done
two things.
You've retrieved the
download URL.
You've used it to retrieve
the file.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly right.
ERIC GILMORE: To really boil
it down to the high level--
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
ERIC GILMORE: That's
what you did.
ALI AFSHAR: Can you think of
any use cases for this?
When would you use this?
ERIC GILMORE: When would
you download a file?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
ERIC GILMORE: Oh my word.
I think we have a number of
drive apps that are doing this
currently, don't we?
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly right.
But say, for example, you've got
a sync client, or you just
want to make a backup
of your drive.
That's the kind of time where
you would use that.
ERIC GILMORE: To isolate
this use case.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
ERIC GILMORE: Perfect,
perfect.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
Right.
On to the next use case.
And that will be exporting
Google Docs files.
Now, Google Docs files don't
have binary content.
OK, that kind of makes sense.
We don't expose the
binary formats.
We don't expose the raw data.
What you can do is download an
export of the Google Doc into
one of the formats that you can
handle, and then you can
understand, OK?
So what we're going to use is
a Google Doc document, and
we're going to export it as
plain text or text HTML.
And we're going to have
a look at that here.
So slightly different
procedure.
The second part will be the
same, actually, downloading,
but the first part, where
do you get the URL?
Well, inside the metadata for
a Google Doc, you have a
dictionary called
export links.
And the keys of the dictionary
are the MIME types.
And the values of the dictionary
are the URL where
you can get the document
for that MIME type.
So let's have a look.
ExportLinks.keys.
So you can see the various MIME
types that we support
there-- text/html,
application/pdf, et cetera.
And if you look at the values,
you'll see they are URLs
almost similar to
each other, with
exportFormat being different.
OK, so in theory, you could
generate these URLs.
We advise that you don't do
that because we make no
guarantee that this
format will remain
constant like this.
So we're going to
use exportLinks.
What should we go for, Eric?
ERIC GILMORE: Did you want to
go for plain text or HTML?
ALI AFSHAR: Let's go for HTML.
ERIC GILMORE: OK.
By the way, there's a table
describing all the mapping of
the formats in our Downloads
topic on the Drive SDK
documentation.
So if you don't like the way
they're listed on Ali's
screen, we have a prettier
list for you.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
Yes, sorry about that.
There is a nice list.
One caveat, it's worth checking
the actual metadata
of each file, because some
files specifically can or
can't download in different
formats.
ERIC GILMORE: And again, you'll
always have the very
latest, up-to-date information
that way, too.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
So there's the URL we're
going to use.
And again, we're going to
http.request, the URL.
And that returns a two pull, as
always, of the response and
the content.
And we've done that quickly.
Let's have a look
at our response
status, 200, fantastic.
And the content, what
do you reckon?
Should we just dump that
to the screen?
We can this time because it's
just a text format, HTML.
And there you go, a
big chunk of HTML.
So as before, open(index).
We're going to save the file
on the local machine.
And we're going to have
a look at it.
Does that sound good?
ERIC GILMORE: Sure.
Can you view it in
the shell here?
ALI AFSHAR: We can try.
I think we can find a text-based
browser here.
So open that, f.write(c)
and f.close.
OK, good.
Let's jump out of the shell.
Let's have a look.
W3m index.hml and
there you go.
So that's my document.
It says, hello world.
Just convince to the people who
are not convinced easily,
I'm one of you, by the way.
I don't convince easily.
But there's my document.
And as you see it, it's
exported it as HTML.
So that's the second
way of doing this.
It's the second type
of download.
And when might you want
to use that, Eric?
ERIC GILMORE: When would I want
to use an export URL?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
ERIC GILMORE: Any time when I'd
like to have a Google Doc,
spreadsheet, some supported
format in a different formats
that's more appropriate
for my application.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, brilliant.
Or if you ever want to download
it or save it offline
or anything like that.
ERIC GILMORE: For saving
it offline.
ALI AFSHAR: Yes.
So that is using the
export links.
Now, that's two of
our methods down.
First one, download URL
for normal files.
Second one, export links
for Google Docs.
And the third way we're going
to show you how to download
things is slightly different
from the other two.
Now, this provides you with
a link, again, a URL
that you can use.
But instead of using it through
the API with API
authorization, this link
can be given to a user.
And the link uses the user's
own cookie auth, if they're
signed into Google, to authorize
the file access.
So they authenticate and
authorize differently.
But this allows a user to
download it in the browser.
When might that be useful?
Well, you want to allow
a user to download
one of their files.
It's a huge video file.
It may be a few gigabytes big.
You don't want to download that
to your server and then
send it to the user.
You don't even want to
stream that across.
You just give them
the right URL.
And if they're logged
in, they download
that to their browser.
They may be using one of the
downloading utilities.
So that all works there.
So really useful, but
slightly different.
It's when you want to provide
that option to the user.
ERIC GILMORE: Sure, and it's
not correct to say that you
can provide this to an
unauthorized user?
ALI AFSHAR: So public files,
a file it doesn't need
authorization, then
you can do that.
ERIC GILMORE: Right, OK.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
But I guess that's one of the
use cases, but not principally
the use case here.
ERIC GILMORE: Right, OK.
ALI AFSHAR: This is better for
big files, or files where you
just don't even want to get
involved in downloading it.
The user just needs to be able
to download that themselves.
So that's have a look at how
we're going to use that.
So again, we're going
to use our image.
Let's just check whether
it's the right one.
Yep, 0.jpg.
And in there, you will see
that there's an attribute
called the web content link.
So that's just another
attribute there.
And we set that to that.
ERIC GILMORE: If we were human
beings talking, or robots.
MALE SPEAKER: And you
are back, Ali.
ALI AFSHAR: I'm back.
MALE SPEAKER: You're back.
ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everyone.
Sorry about that brief
interruption.
But we're back.
So I just showed you how to get
the web content link out
of a file's metadata.
And now I'm going to show
you how to use that.
There we go, as if we haven't
put it on the
screen enough times.
There's the URL.
And as I said, it's going
to use my browser's own
authorization.
You can see that
this browser--
I'm already logged in.
I'm already looking
at the file.
So it won't ask me
to any further.
So I do that, and it pops
up this download thing.
And there we go.
There's the picture
of the dog.
So in that case, I download
it directly in my browser,
because I was authorized,
and I have
access to view the file.
So those are our three methods
of downloading.
Do you want to recap
them, Eric?
ERIC GILMORE: Sure.
They're download URL--
just to make sure I
get this right--
export links, and web
content link.
ALI AFSHAR: That's
exactly right.
So download URL, downloading
binary files in your browser,
export links for downloading
exported versions of Google
Docs using the API, and web
content link for downloading
in the browser.
ERIC GILMORE: It's a pretty
simple two-step dance.
Retrieve the URL appropriately
for your use case, from those
three that we just listed.
And then get the content.
ALI AFSHAR: Perfect.
Now we have additional, slightly
advanced features in
downloading.
We support partial downloads,
if you want to split up the
download into lots of chunks, or
you want to do half now and
half later, or you fail halfway
through a download and
you want to resume.
We support these kind
of features.
That's all in our
documentation.
We advise you to
check that out.
ERIC GILMORE: I have a couple of
questions about things that
we support or don't, Ali.
Would you like to field
a question?
ALI AFSHAR: Sure.
ERIC GILMORE: All right.
I'm not sure what this
means, transloading.
Let's talk about transloading.
This individual wants a user to
click on a button on a page
hosted by user y, which copies
the files from user y's drive
to user x's drive.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
ERIC GILMORE: And vice versa.
OK, maybe I do understand it.
Do we support that?
ALI AFSHAR: Can you read the
question in its full?
ERIC GILMORE: Sure.
I want a user to click on a
button on a page hosted by
user Y, which copies a file from
user y's drive to the x's
drive, or user x's drive.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so currently,
yes, we support that.
It's just a copy operation,
at the end the day.
Your application can download
the file and
then re-upload it.
Or user y can copy the file into
their own drive, and then
share that file, or make
the owner for the
other user, user y.
ERIC GILMORE: There'd be a
requirement that of both of
those users would have to
be authorized for your
application.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so that could
also be done in two steps, so
both users for that flow.
But imagine the situation where
you user y performs this
authorization days or months,
even, in advance of user x.
So there would have to be some
point where the user y says, I
want to share my documents.
I want to share this so
that it can be copied.
So they will put that
into that state.
That's their part of
the application.
In the other part of the
application, the receiver
part, the user who wants to
download that later, they will
need to be authorized there.
Or for that specific
case, you could use
the web content link.
Because as long as the user
has access, then you don't
need to download that
file in the API.
So you can copy the
file across it.
And then they can download it.
ERIC GILMORE: Terrific, Ali.
ALI AFSHAR: So two steps,
copy then share.
ERIC GILMORE: One
more question.
I'm not sure we can answer in
the scope of today's talk.
But can we get an example
of CORS for Drive?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah,
sure, we can.
Actually, there are some, if
you look on Stack Overflow,
there have been a few examples
there of how to do that.
CORS works.
ERIC GILMORE: That's the most
we can say about it.
ALI AFSHAR: Well, I mean, CORS
is kind of, down to the
browser, works out the
finer details.
You make your HTTP, XHTTP
request in the browser.
And then the browser will try
and see if the server has CORS
by sending ahead,
ask the options
which ones it supports.
And if it can, then it will
make that request.
So yes, we do support that.
And yeah, please use it.
And if you have problems,
get back to us.
There are some examples
on Stack Overflow.
If you can't find any, ask a
new question, and one of us
will paste some code for you.
We'd be happy to.
ERIC GILMORE: That's an
interesting question, though,
about transloading.
Maybe we need to have
a session about
sharing sometime soon.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, I think
that's a good idea.
And if any of you are still
watching by now, if you like
the idea of us doing a sharing
session to complement our
sharing Docs, check that out.
This video will be available
in our download
section for the Docs.
ERIC GILMORE: All right.
Well, I hope you've enjoyed
Ali's incredible shell
real-time demo.
I believe he has the ability
to copy it all into a paste
bin for you.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's what
I'm about to do now.
It may or may not work.
If it crashes, I'm sorry.
So paste bin, yes.
It may be too big.
Oh, it worked.
ERIC GILMORE: Did you know
you could do that?
I didn't until this morning.
ALI AFSHAR: It worked.
We should add this URL to the
video description so that you
can look at it.
But if you can see that, it's
bpaste.net/show/49357.
And it's got the entire
session that we
went through there.
ERIC GILMORE: I'll add that
before we leave the room, Ali.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, thank
you, Eric.
ERIC GILMORE: Thank you.